immaginiamo di tornare indietro un
pochino nel tempo andiamo circa nel 1980
po prima di quando è stato fatto liti
c'è la nascita di una nuova industria
e l'industria promettente è basata sulla
nuova tecnologia
ci sono delle grandi corporation che
costruiscono delle macchine basate su
questa nuova tecnologia sono macchine
molto specializzate costano tanto ci
sono tante spin off che fanno macchine
per hobbisti sono così le piccole
apparentemente si vendono ci sono dei
pazzi che sono spazi da comprarle
una di queste spin off già un simbolo la
mela morsicata
li potete immaginare che cosa si tratta
bene questa cosa non sa sono inventata
io in realtà questa l'introduzione di un
articolo di questo signore bill gates ma
lui non stava parlando in questo
articolo del computer come potete
immaginare si applica tanto bene
computer quanto un'altra tecnologia che
questo signore ritiene cambierà il mondo
questa tecnologia la robotica la
situazione è la stessa oggi torniamo
indietro a oggi
abbiamo delle grandi corporation che
costruiscono tanti robot tipicamente su
quelli dell'automazione industriale
ci sono delle spin off che tentano di
fare delle altre cose
più o meno utilizzabili non ci sono
standard stabiliti per cui è difficile
anche prendere un pezzo di un robot
montarlo spesso di un altro robot e
questa cosa non funziona tanto bene
la situazione della stessa la domanda
che si fa bill gates in questo articolo
scientific american
se per caso la robotica raggiungerà la
massa critica tale per ce la troveremo
in tutte le case
questo ovviamente la mia speranza con
robotico
ma non è detto che possa succedere
dipendono certo il numero di fattori
però è una considerazione interessante
io credo che la ricetta in questo caso
possa passare attraverso due diciamo
componenti principali
una è quella di
fare della ricerca su questa ma dentro a
un pochino perché poi nel mio campo
un'altra è quella di trovare delle
applicazioni
in questa immagine presa da un film
abbastanza noto
potete immaginare delle applicazioni
molto sofisticate del robot in casa
ovviamente siamo ben lontani da fare
queste cose
però insomma questo è il sogno è quello
che tutti si immaginano leggendo asimo
immaginandosi i robot umanoidi insomma
io poi questo lavoro fatto per quello
perché un bel giorno qualche anno fa
leggevo anch'io a zero
perché è importante la ricerca
questo grafico che vedete senza cose
troppo complicate una curva che
probabilmente non è neanche del tutto
vera ma la cosiddetta legge della
diffusione della tecnologia si immagina
sostanzialmente che
è una legge psicologica nel senso che
esiste perché le persone parlano tra di
loro cosa vuol dire che quando una
tecnologia si diffonde quello che
succede tipicamente che ci sono dei un
gruppetto piccolo di persone sono gli
innovatori questi qui parlano con gli
amici e gli amici degli amici il
passaparola alla fine fa in modo che ci
sia un gruppo un po più grosso che qui
in inglese si chiamano early adopters
quelli che lo iniziano a usare la
tecnologia questi sono dei pazzi lodate
bene non sono le persone comuni sono
delle persone che è uscito lo schermo
piatto spendono senza poter permettere
solo in realtà 30mila euro per uno
schermo piatto cose incredibili
dopodiché c'è un diciamo pare che se si
raggiunge una certo
percentuale del mercato c'è quello che
si chiama la svolta al tip in point e la
tecnologia si diffonde questo è avvenuto
per i cellulari è venuto prima per
l'automobile
i tempi non sono sempre gli stessi
l'automobile ci ho messo tanto di
fondersi però diciamo il pattern si
ripete ebbene io almeno a me piace
immaginare che nel gruppetto degli
innovatori ci siano i ricercatori di
oggi per questo è importante che questa
tecnologia robotica
sia diffusa tra i ricordi i ricercatori
è che ci sia un gruppo
solido virtuoso di ricercatori che
lavorano in robotica
io in particolare faccio questo lavoro
quello che vedete in questa figura è il
nuovo the che ho realizzato negli ultimi
otto anni progetto che partito
inizialmente come un progetto europeo
come nella mia introduzione
quando sono tornato dal dalle mai ti ho
iniziato questo progetto per cui c'era
una motivazione
bella per tornare in italia con le
possibilità di costruire qualcosa
il progetto andato bene è completamente
open source tra l'altro è questo
funziona bene quei ricercatori perché
abbiamo un sacco di amici che hanno
accolto l'idea di potersi fare un robot
poi
sfortuna vuole che il robot sia
difficile da fare per cui sono stati noi
a far robot rotto e costruito da circa 5
mila parti e molte di queste sono di
meccanica di precisione per cui alla
fine
non è costruire in cantina sono 5 mila
parti perché abbiamo voluto fare la
ferrari dei robot non abbiamo potuto
fare una cosa
per quello messo cose di qualità i
componenti qualità costano
è difficile farli bene e metterli
insieme bene per cui alla fine è open
source e le persone lo usano
ne abbiamo fatti siamo arrivati al
numero di serie 28 siamo riusciti a
venderle 1 in giappone in università
giapponese che per essere un robot
italiano non è male
umanoide peraltro dovete immaginare che
i giapponesi negli anni settanta
facevano già robot umanoidi ce le ruote
suonava il piano per esempio
e poi vedete che sono concentrati tanto
in europa questo perché molti dei fondi
sono fondi che arrivano da finanziamenti
europei per cui è chiaro che c'è più
facilità a comprare l'oggetto in europa
l'oggetto costa un quarto di milione per
cui
diciamo c'è un suo prezzo
ma siamo
diciamo talmente contenti di questo
oggetto adesso vi faccio vedere un video
perché credo che vedere il robot solo in
foto non renda l'idea almeno il video
far vedere qualcosa questo video vedete
che è stato montato però le azioni che
vedete sono tutte reali non l'abbiamo
fatto finta 18 cose che fa robot
normalmente
qui si accende comincia a muoversi
questa è facciamo parte del movimento
sono la sua calibrazione iniziale l'usa
i suoi sensori per capire con esso
dopo di che
può riconoscere oggetti
insomma di varia natura
qui non si sente nel video ma
l'interlocutorio la persona che
interagisce col robot può chiedergli 15
qual è la palla rossa e lui la indica
poi può toccare gli oggetti che vede sul
tavolo e queste operazioni qui nel tempo
lui tocca oggi tocca domani capisce
quelli che sono morbidi quei sono duri
capisce come è fatto un oggetto e impara
anche ad afferrarlo
se riesce ad afferrarlo come in questo
caso qui poi può anche guardarlo meglio
fa un po tutte le cose che farebbe un
bambino se volete alle prese con degli
oggetti nuovi
la cosa è andata tanto bene che
il diciamo abbiamo avuto dei
riconoscimenti
questo non è un riconoscimento
scientifico però ha dato delle
soddisfazioni è uscito un articolo sul
financial times che diceva elogiava la
germania non c'entrava niente con la
germania di per sé lo java la germania
dicendo quanto fa bene all'economia
tedesca qualcosa di questo tipo è come
foto ha messo angela merkel col nostro
robot non sapendo che era un robot
italiano e di stato tutto molto bello
io non è stato in là poi il corriere
della sera ripreso diciamo questo
articolo del financial times dicendo ma
guarda un po elogiano l'economia tedesca
ma il robot è nostro tutto sommato era
cosa simpatica questa foto è reale non è
un montaggio effettivamente l'italia era
partner country alla fiera di hannover
qualche anno fa avevamo come
rappresentante dell'italia tra tante
cose anche ai cup e il che il nome di
questo robot
è passata angela merkel e hanno fatto
questa foto che poi diventata abbastanza
conosciuta ora perché tutto questo è
stato possibile perché qual è il motivo
per cui ci siamo potuti prendere queste
soddisfazioni
tutto sommato
non è solo perché sia stati bravi come
al solito ci vogliono 2 2 o 3 componenti
per fare qualcosa che funzioni una delle
componenti che credo sia stato
fondamentale che contemporaneamente al
nostro progetto europeo di costruzione
progettazione realizzazione di robot
umanoide è nato liti a genova liti
stata una cosa nuova nata nel 2003 nel
2006 è venuto fuori questo edificio
c'era già ma è stato riciclato
dove è stato possibile costruire i
laboratori del nel 2008 liti e diventato
un network per cui quello che vedete in
questa mazzetta sono le varie sedi dove
ci sono dei lavoratori dit il quartier
generale a genova e poi ci sono queste
sedi distaccate che sono tutte in
un'università di eccellenze italiane per
un anno una materia per l'altra
idea è nato con un piano scientifico
ambizioso è riuscita a leggere cosa c'è
scritto in questa slide e ambiziosissimo
andiamo dalle nanotecnologie la robotica
avanzata la neuroscienza scoperta dei
farmaci energia e sicurezza
dell'ambiente
queste cose però non sono staccate
buttate lì ma si compongono in tanti
pezzi la neuroscienza per esempio ci
dice come dovrebbe funzionare il
cervello quando fa certi compiti e noi
possiamo immaginare di utilizzare queste
conoscenze per migliorare come
costruiamo il robot
la scoperta di farmaci chiaramente e di
aiuto alla neuroscienza le
nanotecnologie possono essere utilizzate
per sviluppare nuovi dispositivi che
consentono di trasportare i farmaci dove
servono nel corpo
il piano scientifico
di tia anche una componente di copia
della natura tante volte senza donne
parlare si dice vogliamo comprimere in
15 anni quello che l'evoluzione ha fatto
in quattro miliardi di anni ovviamente
ambizioso qui vedete un grafico che fa
vedere le diverse scale delle cose che
facciamo
partiamo dalle molecole che sono poi i
farmaci
andiamo a scala più grande dove abbiamo
delle palline fate di atomi che possono
portare dei medicinali
possiamo fare delle macchinette o almeno
questo lo scopo finale delle macchinette
intelligenti dei micro robot che
potrebbero essere inseriti nel corpo
umano andare a cercare le cellule malate
e rilasciare il medicinale esattamente
dove c'è la cellula malata possiamo fare
dei micro robot immaginate in caso di un
terremoto avere la possibilità di far
volare delle farfalline robotiche ad
esaminare gli edifici crollati e
possiamo fare il robot a quattro zampe
ad esempio che possono essere utili per
il trasporto in caso di disastro
naturale
terreni accidentati
qualunque situazione dove le strade non
fossero più disponibili possiamo
immaginare queste cose è chiaramente per
quel che mi riguarda possiamo fare robot
umanoidi che dovrebbero rappresentare il
culmine di questa ricerca dove
integriamo tutte queste conoscenze
per costruire qualcosa che poi sia utile
all'essere umano
il compagno robotico che si immagina
nella fantascienza
perché questa ricetta funzionato ci sono
di nuovo vari possibili spiegazioni
una è che abbiamo uno staff
internazionale
e bene delle persone che la vanoni ti
abbiamo un 60 per cento più o meno di
italiani e poi l'altro 40 per cento è
diviso più o meno insomma in maniera
uguale un 25 per cento sono stranieri
un altro 15 o qualcosa sono
italiani sono tornati hanno avuto
l'occasione di vedere una struttura
diciamo di livello internazionale per
cui hanno accettato di tornare dall
università straniere le persone che
lavorano i t sono di 50 paesi diversi
questo momento siamo i 1.200
750 genova il resto sparsi per l'italia
insomma non lo facciamo mistero che
arrivano da tutto il mondo
insomma per genova sicuramente una bella
novità vedere
persone che vengono da posti più
disparati a lavorare
queste persone se guardate in questa
foto ci sono tante faccette se riuscite
a riconoscere l'età di ognuno la media
fa circa 34 anni questo vuol dire che il
gruppo molto giovane anch'io l'ho 25
il altra cosa interessante è che anche a
diciamo per quanto riguarda il gender
balance siamo abbastanza da mesi e 60 40
non è perfetto ma considerando diciamo
quanti difficile tutto sommato entra in
ricerca non è non è così male
ultima cosa prima di proseguire un po
con la robotica finora vi ho detto cose
che potete crederci non crederci magari
non ve dovete tanto bene
quello che credo che invece sia
importante vedere qual è il
riconoscimento internazionale
scientifico questi sono alcuni diciamo
dei giornali dove hanno pubblicato i
miei colleghi soprattutto quelli che
fanno neuroscienze senza materiali ios
un action con la robotica non credo di
arrivarci
ma la cosa importante è che se prendiamo
tutte le pubblicazioni dit e non
l'abbiamo fatto noi l'ha fatto un ente
esterno
e andiamo a vedere la qualità delle
pubblicazioni quindi in quali i giornali
abbiamo pubblicato le mettiamo in un
grafico insieme a quale stato
effettivamente il numero di volte in cui
questo articolo è stato citato da
qualcun altro facciamo un bel grafico ci
troviamo vicino a de marchi stanford il
max planck in germania weissman istituto
in israele quindi siamo in un'area ben
delimitata dove ci sono i migliori
ovviamente se prendiamo a vedere quanto
pubblica il mighty sono 15mila persone
pubblica molto di più ma quello che è
importante non è il numero è anche
quanto è costato farlo noi siamo 1200
per essere 1200 andiamo a vedere anche
qual è il costo per persona o per
pubblicazione scopriamo che siamo molto
vicini altri istituti
copiare se volete
l'umano
per conclude un pochino di nuovo con la
robotica lo vedete questi esempi di
video che fanno vedere l'evoluzione del
robot umanoide il robot che gattona
il
robot che tenta di gattonare una
fallisce miseramente
anche qui abbiamo avuto qualcosa da
imparare
e poi esperimenti di come il robot può
tirarsi in piedi da solo
non facilissimo
e diciamo facendo queste cose noi
abbiamo scoperto per esempio come
copiare la natura nel creare quelli che
si chiamano oscillatori neurali che sono
dei modelli del midollo spinale che
controllano il movimento ritmico degli
arti l'abbiamo scoperto
diciamo anche facendo degli errori
abbiamo scoperto come utilizzare certi
sistemi dinamici per controllare la
generazioni traiettorie complicate come
nel caso in cui lo si tira in piedi
abbiamo visto come si può tenere il
robot fare i primi passi
nell'ultimo video si vede il robot che
fa finalmente i primi passi da solo da
solo questo qui
diciamo tutto sommato in poco tempo se
immaginate
probabilmente conoscete asimo il robot
della honda honda lavorato dieci anni
probabilmente senza dire niente a
nessuno poi far vedere il robot che
cammina ma equa insomma non siamo così
male se
tutto sommato in molto meno tempo
abbiamo un robot che può stare in piedi
fare qualche passo un po titubante ma
ancora ma ce la potrà fare
un'altra cosa importante non è solo il
muoversi nell'ambiente e anche
saper capire cosa sta succedendo nel
mondo in questo esempio vedete ci sono i
sottotitoli c'è una persona che parla
col robot e gli chiede di prendere
quell'oggetto il paul petto
il robot dice mi sa che troppo lontano
non ce la faccio però vede una serie di
attrezzi davanti a sé dice non è che mi
passi quello piccolo
nostro studente lo aiuta a prendere
l'oggetto piccolo
l'oggetto po troppo piccolo per essere
preso dal tavolo dal robot direttamente
ma su quello ci stiamo lavorando e poi
lui capisce o costruisce un movimento
che gli consentì di avvicinarlo e con la
sua lentezza dal robottino ancora a
questo punto poi può muovere la mano
raggiungere l'oggetto ora fin qui la
ricerca applicazioni ci possiamo
immaginare i robot in casa
nell'industria ma quello che credo sarà
importante e l'inaspettato dove useremo
queste cose non lo sappiamo
avremmo immaginato di usare il telefono
per navigare su internet forse no
un'ultima cosa vi lascio con questa
frase perché la prima volta che l'ho
letta mi ha fatto venire i brividi
soprattutto la prima parte dove
diciamo poi vi dico da dove è presa la
frase funziona più o meno così quanti
anni a mi chiese 32 allora lei non può
ricordare com'era il mondo senza i robot
la trovo bella per sta qui di isaac
asimov è presa dai robot grazie